Most people only pay attention to the final product of a successful entrepreneur.
They say things like,
"I can never be like them.” or "They got lucky".
What most don’t see, is what they’ve overcome.
All the struggles, the daily rejections, the
heartaches,
the betrayals, the rumors, the criticism,
the empty bank account and all those lonely
nights while trying to make their vision a
reality.
You see, the only difference between the one who quits
and the one who doesn’t, is that they
showed up every day,
they worked hard every day,
they hustled every day,
they learned from a proven mentor every day,
they improved every day.
They did all this even though they felt like quitting every day.
and eventually they became who they are
today.